[Music]
Welcome to Ai/O—medical school meets garage radio. I'm Teano.
And I'm Ricky. We tune up your cortex in eight minutes flat—oil change not included.
In this pilot episode, we'll explain what Ai/O is and why we chose the eight‑minute format.
We'll also explore a high‑yield medical concept—SIRS versus sepsis—and wrap up with a lightning quiz.
So, why eight minutes? Research shows our brains love micro‑learning. Eight minutes is long enough for a memorable story but short enough to fit into your commute or coffee break.
We promise a daily dose of humor, mnemonics, and memory palaces. Speaking of memory palaces, let's step into our first one.
Imagine you're standing in an emergency room hallway. The fire alarm's sprinkler is going off—spraying water like a high fever. That's SIRS: the sprinkler (temperature), the alarm beep (heart rate), the smoke (respiratory rate), and the fire brigade's white suits (white blood cell count).
Now, sepsis isn't just the sprinkler; it's the sprinkler plus a hidden leak. There's infection and organ dysfunction—maybe the water is contaminated, and it's damaging the electrical panel. That's how you remember sepsis.
So, SIRS is a warning system; sepsis is a system in distress. Visualize the hallway every time you need to recall the criteria.
Ready for a quick quiz? We'll ask three questions. Stick around to check your answers in our app after the episode.
Question 1: What does the sprinkler represent in our memory palace? Question 2: Which extra element makes it sepsis? Question 3: Can you name two SIRS criteria besides fever?
We'll reveal the answers inside the Ai/O app. It'll keep your streak going—and maybe you'll beat Ricky's high score!
Remember: daily practice locks in knowledge. That's why we're here every day with eight‑minute episodes.
Invite friends to join the Ai/O community. For every five referrals, you earn a month of premium access—because learning is more fun together.
Thanks for tuning in. Tomorrow we'll dive into another high‑yield topic with a new memory palace.
This is Teano and Ricky signing off. Now go check your quiz answers and keep that streak alive!